will you commit tonight to accepting the
results of the 2024 election yeah if I
think it's an honest election absolutely
that means no
registered again if I think it's an
honest election I would be honored to
and right now we are so far ahead of
both Democrat and Republican
and you know what if I don't win this
country is going to be in big trouble
it's so sad to see what's happening but
no commitment there on the accepting the
results regardless of the outcome if
it's an honest election correct okay so
not committing to accepting the 2020 or
election results or and Trump just kind
of waves off Caitlyn Collins and the
crowd laughs and everybody has a grand
old time this is dangerous everybody's
laughing off the fact that he did it in
2020 and he's saying he's going to do it
again in 2024 if he loses he will say
that it was rigged
disastrous event for democracy